whether you love it hate it I've never
thought about it chances are some nanny
wants to ban it presenting the nanny of
the month runners-up the FDA for banning
drinks that mix booze with caffeine and
Transportation Secretary Ray LaHood for
just maybe disabling cell phones and
cars I think it will be done either
could take the top slot but there can be
only one nanny of the month in this time
it's oklahoma city mayor Mick Cornett
for blowing the whistle on the lingerie
football league the lfl reverse plans to
add a franchise in Oklahoma City when
the mayor promised to sack the league's
attempt to lease city-owned venues which
have traditionally featured more
wholesome entertainment like the
thundergirls UFC WWE and satanic rituals
say this city of Oklahoma City has made
a deal with the devil the city allowed
this Satanist in his church to rent the
Civic Center to hold what he calls a
blasphemy ritual we have to abide by the
laws of the Constitution of the United
States the satanist held their event in
October but these ladies still aren't
welcome in okc check back later this
month when reason TV announces than any
of the year